[Music]
on this saturday night
ontario's reopening plans why the
province
isn't extending emergency orders despite
the worry over the new variants
[Music]
plus the new way ontario is attempting
to reach the masses
to stop potential super spreader events
the new threat in northern ireland
that's undermining two decades of peace
and celebrating bob marley in canada's
largest city
[Music]
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin tonight with news that the
ontario government is set to loosen
restrictions
next week the province has been in
lockdown since late december and a state
of emergency is set to expire
tuesday cases have declined and
hospitalizations are down
as michael couture reports there may be
reason for optimism
the cancellation of ottawa's winterlude
festival didn't stop skaters from
flocking to the famous rideau canal
with lockdowns across ontario dragging
into their second month
alec lasalle just had to come out for a
skate a lot of people the ice is pretty
good
it's the only thing that you can do
pretty much with all people around
there are limits though by law officers
are patrolling the canal making sure
public health guidelines are respected
right now what we're doing is just we're
bringing awareness just making sure that
people are socially distancing
and that we don't find big gatherings
right now big gatherings are considered
five or more people
those rules will likely remain even as
the province plans to ease other
restrictions
in certain regions this week global news
has confirmed the ford government
is looking at a phased reopening of the
economy in regions where transmission of
the virus
is low welcome news to hard hit
businesses
last year we've made almost no income so
we've got to start picking up soon still
some people are weary
it's good to open and get the businesses
going but
i don't want to see the numbers go back
up some health professionals say we need
to stop looking at those daily case
counts
now that we vaccinated the population at
highest risk
reminding people the goal of the
lockdowns was to take
pressure off the health care system if
you now have cases
we are not having as many
hospitalizations hospitals can handle
that load
and you don't need to restrict things in
the community i'm not saying to open up
to concerts today but i think we can
open up low-risk things first
watch how things happen monitor things
test trace and isolate and we can do
this safely
there is optimism but it is being
tempered somewhat officials are
concerned about this weekend they're
worried that people will get together to
watch the super bowl
and that could turn into many super
spreader events
the government of ontario is running
these chilling ads this weekend
hoping to drive home the point that
social gatherings
are still dangerous a message that could
be all the more necessary
even as provinces ease restrictions in
order to help struggling businesses
mike lacrouter global news ottawa
restrictions may be able to slow the
spread of the virus but it's the vaccine
that will finally help bring our lives
back to normal
so far canada's efforts are lagging
behind dozens of other countries
this week on the west block mercedes
stephenson sits down with the minister
in charge
anita anand mercedes robin it was a
tough week for canada's covid19 vaccine
rollout
both pfizer and moderna face supply
chain disruptions
that are impacting deliveries to the
country but the procurement minister
maintains that we are on track
despite receiving fewer doses than
expected
we have to remember that the entire
globe is seeking access to these
vaccines
and the pressure and the competition is
incredibly intense as production
facilities ramp up
having said that we were one of the
first countries to begin inoculations
one of the first countries to sign with
pfizer and moderna
and we are on track compared to other g7
countries with mass vaccination programs
canada is lagging behind and canada is
lagging behind
35 other countries as of saturday in
terms of doses
administered per 100 people canada had
administered 2.8 doses per 100 people
while the u.s had administered just over
11 doses per 100 people
minister anand tells me she and the
prime minister have been in touch with
the biden administration
to see if canada can access america's
vaccine supply
at the current time u.s domestic
production
of vaccines is attributed and being
attributed
only to u.s citizens but this is a
matter that i'm engaged with our
ambassador on as well as the biden
administration
and we will keep pressing this point on
domestic vaccine delivery schedules
anand says that we can expect some
turbulence
but as the global supply chain
stabilizes canada
should hit its targets i also asked the
minister about when canadians can expect
the astrazeneca vaccine
and press her for more details on those
procurement contracts the government
signed with vaccine suppliers
that'll be this week on the west block
robin all right thanks for that mercedes
the united kingdom appears to be on
track to meet its coven 19 vaccination
targets
more than 11.4 million people have had
their first dose
britain set a goal of vaccinating 15
million people by february 15th
the government hopes to vaccine the next
priority groups including people over
the age of 50
by may and every adult in the country by
the fall
the uk has had the worst coven 19
outbreak in europe with more than a
hundred and ten
thousand confirmed deaths in the u.s
health officials are urging americans
not to attend super bowl parties this
weekend
there's concern the festivities could
turn into super spreader events
the big game is the most watched program
on american television every year
in 2020 more than a hundred million
people tuned in
many at bars and pubs the u.s is seeing
a drop in new coven 19 cases but as
jennifer johnson explains
experts fear that will be short-lived
[Music]
one day before the super bowl fans are
already gathering and cheering
but federal health officials and those
on the front lines are begging americans
to stay home
and avoid partying with friends fearing
this game will be another game changer
in the covet 19 pandemic
i think it's really important that we
don't have these large indoor gatherings
in los angeles county sports bars and
restaurants are prohibited to have tvs
in customer seating areas sunday even
outdoors
there are also fears about private
parties it's the super bowl not the
stupid bowl
don't bring multiple households together
and create a super spreader event
the national football league is allowing
about 25 thousand fans to attend the
game
including thousands of immunized health
care workers but this event will be like
no other
every fan will be still have nobody
seated in front of them
nobody in behind them restrooms which
not only have
physical distancing but touchless it's
the first ever cashless super bowl
the nfl commissioner has told the biden
administration
football stadiums can be used as federal
mass vaccination sites
the pentagon is deploying a thousand
soldiers to help at those sites across
the country
but people with appointments continue to
face cancellations
and frustrations so i was turned away
and i'm very upset
there's a bunch of people up there with
me having the same issues
the push to vaccinate comes as new
variants are spreading fast
the one that originated in south africa
is now in at least three states
the variant that was first detected in
the uk is showing up in even small
remote cities
this person was obviously exposed by
someone else
there is this variant that is already
present
in kalamazoo county the biden
administration is still confident it can
administer 100 million doses
in 100 days adding to the supply johnson
and johnson's vaccine which is expected
to receive federal approval this month
and hundreds of thousands of unused
vaccines from nursing homes
that are being reallocated hope on the
horizon for americans weary
of this almost year-long pandemic
jennifer johnson
global news washington two breaking news
north of toronto police in york region
are reporting at least two people are
dead in a residential neighborhood
police were called to a home in the
community of mount albert for a report
of a stabbing
a woman found injured at the scene was
pronounced dead
three others were taken to hospital with
significant injuries including an
infant a young child and another adult
female
there was an incident or an altercation
with the suspect involving police and
the suspect is now deceased
police investigators remain on the scene
but there is no ongoing safety concerns
to the public the opp will independently
investigate a police officer's conduct
during the arrest of a 20-year-old man
in barrie and a warning the video is
difficult to watch
i'm not even resisting get off of me
the video circulating on social media
shows the police officer holding a
suspect
on the ground during an arrest at one
point the officer hits him with a taser
later he smashes the suspect's head on
the ground
the 20-year-old was charged with causing
a disturbance and assault with an
attempt to resist arrest
the officer has been reassigned pending
the outcome of the investigation
the arrest of a black man in montreal
this week is shining a spotlight on the
city's police department mamadi farah
kamara was held in jail for six nights
before all charges were dropped
montreal's mayor says any independent
investigation looking into what happened
should examine whether racial profiling
played a part
amanda jellowicky reports
mamadi farah kamara's family greeted his
release from prison this week with hugs
and cheers
the phd student and recent immigrant
with no criminal history
walked out of court into a city angry he
was put in prison in the first place
the fact that an innocent man
was put into jail for no reason and i'm
sorry
for what he had to go through
police arrested kamara on january 28th
they accused him with the attempted
murder of a police officer after being
stopped for a traffic violation
he claimed innocence after spending six
nights in jail
prosecutors abruptly dropped all charges
against him
this was another example of police
officers
who indiscriminately target racialized
communities
kamara's case has sparked a furor in
montreal over the police department's
treatment of minorities
there are calls for an independent
inquiry even the prime minister weighing
in
i am certainly one who will watch
closely to see
the answers given on how something like
this could happen
[Music]
[Applause]
allegations of racial profiling have
plagued the force for years
a damning 2019 report indicated police
were far more likely to stop minorities
than white people
after pressure police finally admitted a
problem
exists there is a systemic racism
and it's not only in the police force
last year
montreal police issued new guidelines to
help end racial discrimination
minority groups believe it's all talk
people don't see change but all people
see is
every week every month there's a black
person being mistreated and
you know being a victim of some sort of
miscarriage of justice
some say it's time montreal police wear
body cameras
it's about time we proceed with that and
we should stop
dittering advocates say a real deterrent
to police racial profiling
is jail time for officers found guilty
of profiling and brutality
there needs to be a deterrence mechanism
through the form of sanctions of
penalties
of possibly criminal records as for
montreal police
they face added criticism for refusing
to apologize to camara
they say they're waiting for more
evidence before they do
amanda jeliwicki global news
nova scotia's liberal party has chosen
former forestry minister ian rankin as
its new leader and the province's next
premier
in august outgoing premier stephen
mcneil revealed he would not run in the
next election
and would step aside once the party
picked a new leader
his retirement brings his 17-year career
in politics
to an end coming up concerns about the
peace process
in northern ireland
the military rulers in myanmar have
temporarily pulled the plug
on internet services in the country as
outrage over this week's coup
swells in the streets
thousands of peaceful protesters called
for the release of democratic leader
aung san tsuchi
and other elected politicians detained
since the army seized power on monday
the military junta has been attempting
to silence dissent by blocking social
media access in myanmar
also known as burma the internet
blackout was imposed to prevent the use
of secure networks
human rights groups like amnesty
international say it is a reckless
and heinous move in a time of political
turmoil
and a pandemic cracks are already
appearing in the trade deal that
finalized brexit
it's been over a month since the uk left
behind eu rules and regulations
but in northern ireland tensions over
checks on products transported from
britain
have led to safety concerns for port
workers and politicians
as redmond shannon reports there are
fears this situation could destabilize
the peace process
in the region the reality of brexit is
hitting home
for northern ireland's pro-british
unionists
well i speak for all of my constituents
today
when i tell you that the protocol has
betrayed us
and has made us feel like foreigners in
our own country
checks on goods traveling to northern
ireland from the rest of the uk
have enraged to those who see it as an
affront
to their identity anonymous threats have
been made against politicians and
allegedly
against staff at the seaports we
condemn very strongly any threat
of violence against
port officials or anybody else for
safety reasons port workers were removed
from their posts
for a number of days temporarily leaving
the trade border
wide open the office of anti-brexit mp
stephen fary was among those graffitied
a lot of care needs to be taken to a
what's a very fragile situation in
northern ireland
to keep things moving in the right
direction and we're now
looking into a lot of instability
potentially but brexit isn't the only
cause of tension
in a dispute over vaccines the eu
temporarily and by most assessments
naively overrode the brexit deal
to block vaccine exports to northern
ireland
this is an incredibly hostile and
aggressive act by
the european union block that toxic
blunder has eroded trust in the eu
prime minister boris johnson is even
threatening to do something similar
to free up uk trade to northern ireland
so
how do you square this circle i think
that the way forward will be to have
much lighter checks on goods going from
great britain to northern ireland
the european union will have to take a
few risk stepping in terms of the
integrity of its single market
the uk is requesting that the current
grace period for certain border checks
be extended for two
more years in the interim the search
would continue for that
elusive permanent solution redmond
shannon global news
london still ahead the displays of
resilience at canadian museums
struggling in the pandemic
you're watching global national
[Music]
the pandemic has hurt many businesses
including museums
hundreds of cultural institutions across
the country
rely on revenue from admissions and
volunteers to survive
but for many those things just aren't
possible right now
david aiken has a look at how some
canadian museums are responding to these
challenging times
the africville museum honors and
celebrates the once thriving and
resilient community
for which it's named in the 1960s
halifax city council forcibly removed
its black residents and
raised their homes it would take 40
years for an apology to come in 2010 and
the museum was built a short time later
modeled after the baptist church that
was once the hub
of africville's residents it was a
cultural hub for the african nova
scotian community especially people of
africville
but today as a museum it's it serves to
welcome people into this space and and
see why this space was so important to
people of africville but this museum
like so many others across the country
has been shut to visitors since last
spring
but rather than wait for visitors to
return museums are reaching out in
new ways for the africville museum it
was a cookbook project
a collection of recipes contributed by
former africville residents
people from all over the city and the
country are buying copies
what is the thing that often brings us
together food
it was such a great challenge at the
museum in swift current
staff responded to the pandemic by
mounting an exhibition
with the public's help to document how
those in southwest saskatchewan
lived through the first lockdown this
exhibition is called
pandemic pastimes photos and stories
about
what life was like last spring the
closing of the skate park
the closing of the playgrounds and all
these artifacts will be archived by the
museum for
future researchers so a hundred years
from now
people are going to be able to actually
do an
exhibition and have local information
in west kelowna the west bank first
nation had just moved its museum to this
mall when the pandemic hit
its doors shut cora lee miller started
reaching a new audience
with a series of popular upbeat videos
from
inside the museum there's too much doom
and gloom on the news already at least
with this we can get people to forget
about their problems at least
just for a little bit now all three of
those museums were among
1200 institutions right across the
country
that received emergency federal funding
twenty thousand here
forty thousand there all of it to keep
their essential programming going
museum advocates though say more will be
needed if museums have to stay closed
for a second summer in a row
robin david aiken in ottawa thanks david
and david will have more on how canada's
small museums are documenting the
pandemic for generations to come
that's tonight on the new reality with
donna friesen right here on global
up next one canadian city is giving the
late bob marley
a lot of love
in this great future
the unforgettable bob marley is being
celebrated on what would have been his
76th birthday
it's been almost 30 years since the
reggae legend died of cancer
[Music]
marley's family released a version of
his hit song one love
in support of unicef's work with
children affected by covet 19.
and today toronto's mayor joined in on
the importance of marley's lyrics
which focus on tolerance
and that is why i'm so proud on behalf
of the members of toronto city council
to proclaim
today february the 6th 2021
as bob marley day in the city of toronto
may his legacy live on
may we take to heart what he believed in
so much and what his music stands for
which is more love
and more peace and more bob marley
the mayor adds through the power of his
songs bob marley became one of the
greatest ambassadors of peace
around the world and that is global
national for this saturday
i'm robin gill tonight your canada is
the sun setting behind the golden years
bridge
viewed from maple ridge bc we would love
to see you're part of this beautiful
country so email your photos to viewers
at globalnational.com
thank you for watching and i'll see you
back here tomorrow have a great night
you